hi there steve here again 90 day korean
challenge you know i am enjoying it i
may go beyond my 90 days it's just so
easy to do now
and i want to talk today about
the whole mobile computing
world
i saw a tweet today which i retweeted if
any of you follow me lingo steve on
twitter
and it showed that
basically it showed a graph of people
accessing the internet via mobile
devices such as smartphones and tablets
versus people access accessing the
internet from the computer and of course
the number of people accessing the
internet by a computer is declining and
the people accessing the internet via
mobile devices is increasing and it now
passed so more people access the
internet via mobile devices than via the
computer which is very interesting to me
because i mean language learning okay i
studied french at school we had to go
through these boring stories that nobody
that we didn't get to choose it was all
very boring
uh but eventually i got to go to france
blah blah blah then i studied chinese
there i had the open real cassette at
least a tape recorder eventually we got
down to the cds i would always wind
themselves in a in a knot
and then eventually i can still remember
the first before the apple computer they
had these little
not pac-man but you know like ping pong
you had to sort of have your bat go up
to me that was the beginning of the
personal computer that was in 198
maybe late 1970s
then the apple came out not the apple
but i can't remember what it was called
in those days it was the apple i bought
them i got totally hooked on them but
anyway
uh so the computer was a thing but
nowadays when it comes to language
learning i have everything i want
basically on my
iphone
and it's kind of amazing i mean i i can
link
using our app which is still in beta so
if you are interested you can get on the
forum or
contact customer support you can get it
it's it just it's just tremendous i can
read i can listen i can look up words
i can do my vocabulary review
uh a friend of mine in germany has an
app now that she's developing
which will enable people to find
others in the neighborhood who are
native speakers of the language they're
learning so we can face time with people
we can
more and more things we can do on this
little device
whether it be an iphone or an android or
whatever
it's just amazing it's just so you know
i don't have to sign up for a
three-month course or anything i just
i just do what i do on here and and um
you know i can i i
accessing all kinds of new lessons on
link that other people are putting up
for me and
it's just amazing the the degree to
which we can
be mobile
i guess the disadvantages i began by
talking about twitter uh the
distractions because i follow different
people on
twitter
who are journalists or news sources and
stuff so i'm up to date on what's
happening and the temptation always is
in the middle of reading through a
korean lesson i'll check out what's
happening on twitter so you got to be
you got to be a little disciplined
but beyond that though the the
convenience of mobile learning language
learning mobile language learning it's
it's just it just it's so powerful
whether you go to a class or don't go to
a class it doesn't matter you still have
to learn on your own and
the world is at your fingertips with
these devices so that's what i wanted to
mention today
and now i'm going to charge off and do
some more korean reading bye for now